des petits pas fondées grande distance
j'ai le plaisir de vous faire partager
une grande aventure pour le petit
marcheurs que je suis c'est l'ascension
du cho oyu show you ou la ds la ds
courte turquoise le shoyu est à côté de
l'everest en frontière entre le tibet et
le népal
je participe à une expédition orléanaise
de cinq personnes auquel s'adjoint un
guide français est un très grand sherpa
qui a déjà à son actif deux fois
l'ascension de l'everest et plusieurs
fois l'ascension du cho oyu ainsi que
deux cuisiniers imaginé cette équipe
traverse l'himalaya du sud vers le nord
nous voici arrivés sur le plateau
tibétain a thing gris tigré 4100 mètres
d'altitude
nous transférons nos 600 kg de matériel
sur les quinze diack accompagné de deux
semaines et nous mentons tranquillement
vers le camp de base du cho oyu sous le
charme et les chants des yaks mène le
camp de base du cho oyu se trouve à 5600
mètres d'altitude
sachez qu'à 5600 mètres d'altitude il ne
reste que 50 % d'oxygène une grande
angoisse me prends mon esprit va dans
tous les sens la vie la mort je respire
avec difficulté
au bout de deux nuits mon subconscient
arrive à maîtriser cette angoisse j'ai
gardé mes alertes de survie
nous allons monter le shoyu en technique
himalayenne cela consiste à monter
quatre camps successifs ainsi que de
placer des cordes fixes le long des
parois de neige de glace verticale me
voilà au camp 3 à 7600 mètres d'altitude
à 7600 mètres d'altitude il ne reste que
35% d'oxygène par rapport au niveau de
la mer à ma grande surprise arrive un
camarade d'expédition qui normalement ne
devait pas monter si regard de son
extrême fatigue le risque de dème et le
risque qui fait prendre à l'ensemble de
l'expédition
le guide est furieux il me dit claude
occupe toi de ton ami c'est avec grande
compassion à 7600 mètres d'altitude
il faut beaucoup d'énergie je prépare
des repas lyophilisés pour cela il faut
faire fondre de la neige je m'installe
dans la tente et je prépare sa descente
avec d'autres membres d'expédition au
petit matin
à ma grande surprise le guide et le chat
repas sont partis vers le sommet je
réveille pierre un de mes camarades de
cordée et lui dit suivons les assets
1800 mètres d'altitude
pierre décide de rebrousser chemin et on
se donne rendez vous au camp trois mois
je continue seul lors de mon voyage
solitaire je rencontre mon père je
dialogue avec lui arriver à l'arête
sommitale du cho oyu je vois le guide
est le sherpa descendre
personnellement je suis dans un état
second
je réalise que je fais cinq grandes
respirations pour avancer d'un tout
petit pas ils me disent nous sommes trop
fatigué la nuit va tomber il faut
rebrousser chemin pour un alpiniste si
proche du but après avoir organisé une
telle expédition
c'est difficile de rebrousser chemin mon
cerveau pas de problème il décide de
revenir et j'ai besoin je lave ou du
soutien du sherpa pour arriver au camp 3
je vous ai raconté cette histoire
pour deux raisons la première c'est par
rapport à la méthode que moi même j'ai
employé à partir de l'objectif
l'objectif j'allais travailler pendant
une année complète
je les écris je les répéter plusieurs
fois par jour toutes les cellules de mon
corps adhérer à cet objectif
l'objectif est le suivant revenir en vit
à orléans
là où j'habite olivier exactement en
tentant l'ascension du cho oyu sommets
de 8000 201 m sans apport d'oxygène
complémentaires par ailleurs la méthode
vous invite à vous assurer la
compatibilité des différents objectifs
que vous pouvez revoir familiaux
professionnels
troisièmement il s'agit de bien
déterminer vos points forts et vos
points de faiblesse et bien entendu
travailler nos points de faiblesse
ton voyage vers un objectif il est très
important de prêter attention aux
chemins c'est toujours le chemin qui
nous enseigne la meilleure façon d'y
parvenir
l'ascension d'une montagne n'est pas
qu'une question de courage
c'est aussi une question de sagesse et
d'intelligence
je souligne ainsi la voie l'importance
d'avoir un projet qui nous motive d'être
enthousiaste de monter une équipe de
définir l'objectif est que cet objectif
soit partagé la deuxième raison vous
pensez que je n'ai pas atteint mon
objectif mais il n'en est rien mon
objectif était bien de revenir en vie
orléans j'évolue à plus de 8000 m
certainement à 8100 m j'étais à 150 m de
dénivelé du sommet
mieux que ça je me sens grandi d'avoir
finalement peut-être au détriment
d'avoir atteint le sommet mais grandit
d'avoir été d'avoir aidé un copain à
revenir lui aussi envie à orléans je lui
je suis persuadé sa sauvé la vie alors
pourquoi aller toujours plus haut plus
fort plus vite plus loin c'est ce que
les médias nous présentent aujourd'hui
la recherche des performances pour les
sportifs nécessite de se doper
sans dopage pour beaucoup d'entre eux
pas de record pas de record
pas de public pas de public pas d'argent
moi je ne marche ni trop vite ni trop
lentement mais en respectant les lois et
les nécessités du chemin
je suis à la recherche de l'effort pure
sans artifice l'adaptation du corps et
de l'esprit à la pleine nature
je veux vous souligner ici l'importance
d'avoir une éthique
la fin ne justifie pas les moyens
ma phrase fétiche
fruit de plusieurs années de réflexion
en parcourant en pleine nature les cinq
continents et vive la vie la vie est
belle mais elle est courte et elle se
prolonge cette phrase sous tend que la
vie est aussi fait de difficultés de
souffrance qu'il faut savoir dépasser et
donc se dépasser
la compréhension sur les raisons qui me
poussent à m'investir dans les
situations hors norme vient d'une double
recherche
la première et ma capacité à m'adapter à
rebondir à partir d'expériences en
pleine nature
on est petit face à la nature
si petit que l'on voit à l'intérieur de
soi et ont grandi d'une telle recherche
l'introspection ont grandi au point de
se surpasser de réaliser l'irréalisable
et comme disait saint-exupéry
il ne savait pas que c'était impossible
alors il l'a fait mais catherine
destivelle rajoute tout de suite à
chacun son everest
il s'agit pas de mettre la barre trop je
suis dit ainsi l'importance de s'adapter
en fonction des événements de ne pas
ménager ses efforts tout est possible a
qui rêvent aux travail et n'abandonne
pas la deuxième recherche et d'aller à
la rencontre de mon père mon père était
pilote de chasse dans l'aéronavale
il pilotait l'avion le corsaire et il
est tombé au dessus du caire dans les
événements de suez le 5 novembre 1956
maman mes soeurs et moi
âgé à peine de 6 ans vivions à bizerte
j'ai réalisé bien tard que j'étais si
petit pour vivre un si grand drame
serait ce la recherche du père manquant
pour ne pas être le fils manqué maquette
à l'extrême
concernant l'anecdote de la rencontre et
du dialogue de mon père avec mon père
sur l'arête sommitale au show you sachez
que l'avion de retour au lieu de faire
escale à hambourg a fait escale au caire
où mon père a disparu et je sais que
pour rencontrer mon père je dois mener
un effort particulièrement important ce
que je veux dire ici en vous dévoilant
ma propre recherche personnelle c'est
l'importance de se connaître de se
comprendre de s'aimer et de faire son
propre cheminement intérieur tout en
vivant le moment présent
l'homme est issu de la complexité de la
nature
il est grand à côté de l'être vivant
complexe qu'est la bei mais il est tout
petit tout petit à l'échelle du cosmos
l'homme peut être petit ridiculement
petit à détruire mes grands très grands
a créé à innover à produire du positif à
travailler pour le bien de tous ma
marche de deux mois au japon
les deux pelés petitpas faisant des
grandes distances notamment en
gravissant les montagnes sacrées le mont
fuji
mais aussi en parcourant à pied les
grands pèlerinages du coup à nos coteaux
et des 88 amp de shikoku m'ont fait
prendre le chemin spirituel
vous comprenez ainsi maintenu de
pèlerins qui reprend
en cette évolution ou la recherche de la
performance est devenu secondaire au
profit de ce cheminement spirituel
je vous invite ainsi à revisiter votre
définition de la performance j'ai bien
entendu pas dit de l'abandonner et à
prendre le temps d'accomplir le chemin
spirituel tout en respectant la nature
vive la vie la vie est belle mais elle
est courte et elle se prolonge
je vous remercie